hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
total beliebten klassiker die
kombination die kind wirklich jeder
schokoladen website schokoladen streusel
und käsekuchen habt ihr schon erraten
geworden okay ist ja und russischer
zupfkuchen ist muss ich sagen es steht
aber auch schon im titel
also können wir direkt loslegen wir
machen wir nicht jetzt erstmal ab und
dann zeige ich euch die käsekuchen masse
wir benötigen mehr weiche butter
außerdem eier zucker kakao und
backpulver so für den teig müssen jetzt
ganz einfach die sechs zutaten nicht
gerade gezeigt habe miteinander
verbinden ich nämlich zuallererst die
weiche butter und verrührt das mit dem
zucker und dann gebe ich die restlichen
zutaten dazu
[Musik]
und sobald die trockenen zutaten drin
wird merkt ihr dass der teig ein
bisschen schwerer wird und dann nimmt
euch am besten die sauberen hände und
knete zum paar minuten mit den händen
weiter sobald sich dann die zutaten
verbunden haben ist der teig fertig und
wir sparen und sitzt ungefähr ein
viertel bis ein drittel auf gebe ich
jetzt hier an die seite das sind nämlich
später unsere streusel jetzt sehen wir
uns den teig und eine springform ich
habe 40 26 cm durchmesser den boden mit
backpapier ausgekleidet und jetzt ganz
einfach den boden und die ränder
auskleiden mit dem teig
so der teil wäre erledigt die ränder
habe ich ja hochgezogen so ungefähr
viereinhalb zentimeter
da könnte einfach schauen wie ich das am
besten passt könnte die rennen noch so
ein bisschen gerade abschneiden und
jetzt machen wir allerdings weiter mit
der käsekuchen füllung den pinsel für
die streusel übrig haben den brauchen
wird gleich jetzt und ich hole nur ganz
für die zutaten und zeigt euch dann für
die käsekuchen masse benötigen wir milch
magerquark außerdem eier und zucker
geschmolzen und abgekühlte butter
speisestärke vanillezucker und eine
prise salz und ich bin uns jetzt gar
keine küchenmaschine kein handrührgerät
mir reicht da schon ein schneebesen
nehme mir jetzt einfach eine ausreichend
große schüssel und vereine alle zutaten
darin die reihenfolge ist dabei egal
sondern immer mal eier und milch und
dann versuche ich das erstmal
[Musik]
so prise salz hebt noch einmal den süßen
geschmack und jetzt speisestärke und
vanillezucker und statt der beiden
zutaten könnt ihr auch ein päckchen
vanillepudding pulver nehmen aber hier
ist einfach natürlicher
[Musik]
so dem boden halte ich es nur kurz im
kühlschrank weiter so warm ist durch die
soft boxen und jetzt eben gehen wir
einfach die käsekuchen masse darauf
zurück noch mal ganz kurz für mich ihn
frei
[Musik]
und hier ist der übrig gebliebene schoko
teig den nehmen wir also streusel artig
drüber lacht da wo ich immer ein
bisschen abstand denn das ist die
typische form des russischen zupfkuchen
und ich liebe das das schmeckt so lecker
am ende
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann zufrieden sein mit eurem
muster gibt ihr das ganze in den
vorgeheizten backofen 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für 55 bis 60 minuten und
anschließen müssen wir vollständig
auskühlen das könnt ihr gerne auch schon
am vortag zubereiten und am nächsten tag
geht es dann richtig schön kühl und
schön fest geworden
nach der backzeit ist der russische
zupfkuchen noch ein bisschen wackelig
das ist ganz normal
er muss wirklich komplett aus gewinner
so gibt ihnen die zeit und dann könnt
ihr euren russischen zupfkuchen genießen
ich liebe das es so so lecker und falls
euch das video gefallen hat dann gibt
mir auf jeden fall ein bäumchen nach
oben also wer jetzt lust hat auf diesen
kuchen auf jeden fall im dörfchen
hinterlassen die genauen mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch natürlich hier und in
die infobox wie immer
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen
kanal kostenlos abonniert fällt ihr das
nicht schon längst getan habt und dann
sehen wir uns das nächste mal wieder auf
die gis kitchen
ja
[Musik]